ونحييكم مشاهدينا ومتابعينا من جديد في
لبنان فوجئ الوسط السياسي بشني رئيس
التيار الوطني الحر نائب جبران باسي
الهجوما على خصومه وحلفائه وعلى راسهم من
الشيخ حزب الله مهددا بانه سيترشح للرئاسه
في لبنان باسيل صرح بانه يفكر جديا
فترشحين لرئاسه الجمهوريه بغض النظر عن
الخسائر والمكاسب ضارب جهود مؤيديه
ومعارضه لحل معتله الملف رئاسيه وخصوصا من
قبل حليفه نصر الله ورئيس البرلمان نبيه
بري الريق وعن مستقبل علاقته مع حزب الله
المح وجه جبران بسير الى ان التيار الوطني
الحر مستعد لعقده تفاهم جديد مع اي مكون
جديد تحت عنوان بناء الدوله قائد الجيش
جوزيف عون والذي يرشحه بعض الفرقات
للرئاسه لم يسلم هو الاخر من هجوم باسيل
فقد اتهموه بانه يخالف قوانين الدفاع
والمحاس العموميه وياخذ بقوه صلاحيات وزير
الدفاع على حد قولي بسيط
وهيك بتكون الشراكي ضمانه بس ما بتكون
ضحيه للحفاظ عليه نحن مستعدين
حسبي الله ومع اي مكون سياسي حول بناء
الدوله
للاسف
يبدو مقتنعت معنى المؤلمه
لا يقبلوا في كل اللبنانيين في ناس اليوم
خايفه على التفاهم وانا على راسي البلد
وناقش وانا افهم هذه التصريحات مع ضيوفنا
هنا في السجن في البرلمان اللبناني اهلا
بك ومن بيروت ملكه الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بك
معنا يا استاذ مالك واسمح لي ان ابدا هنا
في الاستوديو مع ضيفه سيد عطوان في
الواقعه هذه تصريحات جبران باسيل تعلم
حضرتك كذلك من بيروت بانها ليست الاولى
جبران باسيل كانت لها تصريحات من شهر كان
انتقد كذلك حسن نصر الله على خلفيه كما
قال هو بانه
عوده تجاهها في الانتخابات كذلك في مايو
2022 كانت لها انتقادات
في او على لوائح مختلفه ولكن هذه
التصريحات بالذات استوقفت الكل في الداخل
والخارج لماذا همم مساء الخير لا حضرتك
الكرام بالواقع بالشكل اولا نعتذر
اللبنانيون يوم الاحد اللي بيسموه يوم
الرب الرب ان يستمعوا الى ربط طلاب
والمطران عوده
يسمع ارشادا ايجابيا ينطلق من مسلمات
دينيه واجتماعيه ووطنيه ويرتاحوا هذا يوم
الرب عم بيفاجئهم الوزير جبران باسيل
بالمرحله الاخيره
بانه يوازن بين الخير اللي تلاقوه صباحا
والتفرقه اللي بيبصها مساءا وكانهم لم
يمضوا يوم الرب يعني عم بيعكر صفو هذا
النهار
القادمه
لا يفهم همم الوزير جبران بسيل الا عندما
وكبه من بدايته السياسيه حتى اليوم
اساسا العهد الذي انطلق مع العماد مش
شرعون في العام 2006 لو لم يكن لم تكن
النيه المبيته والواضحه تماما
واكد عليها جبران باسيل انه هذا عهد يمهد
لعهد جبران باسيل وليس عهدا بحد ذاته يعني
كانت الفكره الولايه 12 سنه سته
جبران لربما كانت نتائج العهد اقل كارثيه
من ما وصل اليه منذ وصول عماد هون بدا
السعي لتوريد جبران باسيل وبدا على هذه
الطريق يطيح بالحلفاء والاصدقاء واحدا تلو
الاخر الاخر
وبنى مجده السياسي على خطاب الدوله
تبخر وبده يذكر انه الوزير جبران بيصير من
بعد تفاهم مع راب واجراء الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في العام 2016
فورا اعلن انه كرسنا مبدا الاقوى في
طائفتته يمثل الطائفه في الحب يعني مثل ما
نبيه بري هو الاقوى عند الشيعه يمثلون صار
له حريري عند السنه عند المسيحيين
هلامهم بالعهد
22 سنه
هل كان ريهانا فعلا من الحلفاء على جبران
باسيل واختلفت الامور الفتره الماضيه
مساء الخير تحيه للجمهور الكريم
وللزميلكريم اولا سوف ابدا بالشكل
لم يستعمل يوما الكنيسه والكهنه والمطارنا
ليهاجم بالسياسه كما يفعل الدكتور جاجا
سنويا وفي كل مناسبه للقوات اللبنانيه هذا
هذا وانتهى كلامي لراجع مناسبات السياسيه
التي
يصرح بها الدكتور جاء تكون خلال قداس
وبوجود مطارنا وبوجود همم
هذا لم نفعله في حياتنا هذا برد بالشكل
اما بموضوع ال همم جبران بسيل وكل حزب
سياسي في لبنان وفي العالم كله يسعى لان
ياتي بزعيمه الى السلطه كما يفعل كما تفعل
القوات اللبنانيه كما يفعل حزب المستقبل
كما تفعل حركه امل وهذا حق سياسي طالما هو
لا يخالف القانون
طالما هو لا يخالف القانون وهذا قد يكون
صنعه التيار نعم هذا صنعه التيار ويصنعه
اي حزب سياسي ولكن الاساس بالموضوع هل
اخطا العهد واخطا ميشال عون وخالف القانون
ليقوم بهذه الاعمال هنا هذا الكلام وهنا
يجب التقييم في ذلك اما الكلام وجبران
هل اخطا العهد هل اخطا التيار في طرح مثلا
جبران باسيل همم يعني طرحه الاسم وفيما
بعد صارت اختلافات حول الشخص ان كان قادر
على ان يرشح او يتقدم ابدا كيف ابدا ابدا
انا اتحدث ان يكون هناك اي بيان سياسي
للتيار او لرئاسه الجمهوريه منذ
العماد عون همم سده الرئاسه ان يكون روج
وقال ان يرشح قال الوزير الاول
يعني حتى ولكن كل اوساط تتحدث عن ذلك التي
هي ضد التي هي ضد السياسه التي هي ضد
السياسه يا سيدتي وهذا حق هذا عمل سياسي
ونحن علينا وعليك
لما تحدثت ان جبران بشير كان المرشح تحدث
كما قال ضيفي لانك من المعارضه او تعارض
هذه الفكره او السناد على معلومات
اما اذا كان كل الناس تعرف انه لا مرشح
لجبران باسيل الا جبران بصير رغم كل
المناورات السياسيه التي يقوم بها انه
خلونا نتفاهم خلونا نتفق خلونا نحكي باسم
خلونا خلونه
والاسوا انه كلمه حكى عن ترشيحه بيترحه
باطار تحدي يعني انه انتبهوا زمان مشيتوا
بترشح انا يعني اذا ما اكتفيته بالمره
عليكم بيجيكم اللي هو انا واللي هو اصلا
الامارات
جدل كبير وكانه البعض اعتبر بانه هذا
التهديد فكيف يرشح الشخص نفسه ويضع هذا
الترجيح في صيغتها
اذا انا بوصل بتشوفه مش شايف امه اللي
بتكون تشوفوه اثنين فجعنا انفعاله للاستاذ
عرفته عنه كاتب صحفي طلع ملتزم حزبه بده
يقاتل ما انا مش جاي
قاتلنا كمان همم
تقول نحن تتحدث عن الحزب تتحدث عن التيار
صحيح
الخلاصه وقت
اللي كل الناس تعرف شو هو مكمل الخلاف ما
حزب الله اليوم
دلوني على مخالفه انونيه من اجل توريد
جبران بس ما حدا حكى عنه
في مخالفه في دستوريه المخالفه الدستوريه
هي تجوير السياده اللبنانيه سياسه الخارجي
والسياسه الدفاعيه الى ميليشيا حزب الله
من اجل الحصول على تاييدهم كامل وافتراض
انه مقابل ما اعطينا الحزب من غطاء رسمي
وشعبي لبناني كي يقوم بما يقوم به على
صعيد مهمته الاقليميه وانتماؤه الى الحرس
الثوري الايراني والحرف في سوريا وفي
اليمن وفي ايران مش في ايران في سوريا وفي
اليمن وتدخل بالعراق وبالبحرين والى اخره
مقابل هذا كله واجبات الحز بيضل ملتزم
بالتحالف معنا وباصار رئيس التيار الوطني
انت ليست قائمه اليوم وهذه بتخليه بكل مره
يردد انه وينها التحالف شو عملتوا وبيحطوا
تحت اطار بناء الدوله انه ما مشيتوا معنا
بمشروع بناء الدوله بالواقع الكل يفهم ولا
لست وحدي والكل يفسر انه عدم حماس حزب
الله لتقرار تجربه العماد عون بتاييد
الوزير جوان بيصير الجمهوريه والذهاب الى
تاييد افرنجي دون اعلان حتى اللحظه
والاستعداد بخطابات
للبحث بمرشح توافق ايه ليس بينهم
لم يعد يرى نفسه
اسيل قالوا منذ شهر قال بانه حزب الله وعد
واخلف وعده وهنا سؤال همم سيد نادر هل هذه
بدايه خلاف عميق بين التيار والحزب
عندما قال ان حزب الله وعد اخلف بوعده هو
ليس بموضوع الرئاسه بل بموضوع حضور جلسات
الحكومه المستقيله هو كان قبل قبل عند
تكليف الرئيس ميقاته وعندما فشل الرئيس
ميقاتي في تكليف في تشكيل الحكومه
ويبدو ان هناك واحد وكان هناك خشه لا ده
رئيس الجمهوريه ولا رئيس
بان تعقد جلسات للحكومه المستقيله همم هنا
همم هنا يبدو ان هذا الوعد كان
صح يا كان موضوع علم الحكومه ولكن خلينا
نحكي على العلاقه بين التيار والحزب فقدنا
ضيفنا او يعود طيب سننتظر لبعض الوقت ولكن
سانقل لك سؤال
سيد نادر همم من جديد سيد نادر هل هي
القطيعه الحقيقيه بين التيار والحزب
الله
وجهه النظر بموضوع رئاسه جمهوريه وهذا
موضوع مهم وكبير وهناك اختلاف ايضا من
وجهه نظر بموضوع الحكومه وهذا ايضا
بالنسبه الوطن الحر وللمساقيه في البلد هو
موضوع مهم وخطير واذا حصل اذا حصل الطلاق
همم حصل خلاف اذا حصل خلاف
جزيلا لكم في البرلمان اللبناني ومن بيروت
ملكه الكاتب الصحفي على ضيق الوقت للنقاش
دائما همم استكمال في حلقات الاخرى السلام
عليكم